obviously like before we talk about
music i have to thank you
because i find you to be just so
open and honest i love that you share in
such a profound way like i just
it's just nice for another human to be
this way and it and i know it means a
lot to other people like just between
like sobriety
um your sexuality um lots of different
topics i just find you to be a ve
like very much an open book wow that
means
a lot thank you yeah uh yeah i really
really really
really appreciate that i haven't really
heard that
it's definitely um it is something that
i
i i am very compelled to do
is just be honest and open and i i have
a lot of issues with i've always had
issues with becoming uh
somebody in the public eye and ever
since i was a kid i always had a lot of
anxiety when people recognized me
and i want to
be somebody that people can look up to
and just um
i don't know i've always felt out of
place uh in whatever i do
and so i want to make people feel safe
and like you know i'm not this
this unreachable object you know i want
people to
i just want to be open with everybody
and and let people know that i'm
i'm i'm the same as as everybody else
i love that so thank you for saying that
that's awesome
no thanks i mean thanks for being you i
mean do you have fans that thank you for
being real or like message you and say
like hey
that meant a lot to me thank you for
sharing that like do you get that kind
of feedback from your fans
i do yeah and i try to um
there's a lot of fans that that i really
try to have like a relationship with
and there's some that have like messaged
me through really dark times in their
lives and i end up getting their like
phone number and text
and make sure that that they're doing
okay
um so i do i do i do hear that yeah
definitely
um i have been trying to kind of stay
off of the message boards and comment
section of social media lately so i
haven't really been
uh i haven't seen it too often lately
but um but there definitely are a lot of
people who
who have come up to me in person too and
told me that um
that i've really helped kind of you know
get them out of the dark place
or or they're just thankful for me being
open and honest
it's really nice yeah does it relieve
your
anxiety just being able to be your 100
like authentic self do you feel like
you're able to be
a 100 authentic self oh yeah sure
there's nothing
there's nothing good i i don't have the
capacity or the capability to
fake yeah you know if i'm like having a
bad day like it's
definitely noticeable you know so i'm
i'm always
always myself and i i i don't feel like
um
like it's hard for me to be
that way uh and does it release all my
anxiety
i mean yeah i think so yeah
i feel like if i were to pretend to be
somebody else i maybe i wouldn't maybe i
feel less anxious
because you know airing out your laundry
and like getting everything out there
there's some negative consequences that
come from that and i've
i've kind of been exposed to that and so
that but you know i'd rather be
like i just got jesus tattooed on my
back and i love that
part of the reason why i did that um
is because i've been really into the
idea of
of somebody sacrificing themselves for
like for the population for people and
so
so i i'm not comparing myself to jesus i
i
i understand what you're saying though
you know so like yeah
so even if i do get anxious or it causes
more anxiety
being more honest with my uh about
myself
i'd prefer that because i think in the
long run it has a more positive effect
i think i'm still kind of experimenting
but you know
i don't know how to be any other way i
love that and obviously you know
the more open you are like you said it
does have negative consequences in some
ways sadly
and we've seen it and i know you've said
before like
there were headlines that you officially
came out as either pansexual or bi and
then you said like
wait i never said that yeah so like yeah
how does that even how do you even deal
with that when you get you wake up in
the morning you see headlines like that
and you're like
no that's not what happened well i mean
i think people are going to label me no
matter what like that's that's the thing
about like
yeah me really wanting to be honest and
authentic
and and transparent is that like uh
i i have this drive to do it because
it's
i'm never i don't know if any i don't
know how people see me like that's why
i'm really
grateful that you said that because like
it seems like it's finally starting to
break through
yeah um but uh yeah
waking up to those uh i did have anxiety
i think i think i just have anxiety
whenever i'm in the headlines of
something you know and
it's just uh it just feels unnatural um
and then i had it really i at that point
i hadn't
mentioned anything about it to my
parents you know my dad and so i was
like
all right well i guess this is a good
way to break the ice on this and he
called me about it
and um and everything was cool and
i explained it to him and but you know i
i feel like that was sort of even if
people were mislabeling me
yeah um i feel like it was sort of a
positive kind of thing you know which in
that like my girlfriend kind of helped
me sort of
realize that uh i rather than pansexual
i'm sexually fluid
and you know that fits under the queer
and lgbtq you know universe and so
i'm i i love i love being
um you know brought into that world
and and being a part of the lgbtq
community so
i'm all for it if you want to mention
that well i find your honesty refreshing
and i think
everybody if everyone shared their
stories we would get so much further in
life just in general
the fact that we don't share as much
openly makes me crazy so
the fact that you do it like love it
like superheroes
you and it takes so much courage to do
that so thank you i appreciate that
of you and i have to ask too like you
know do you like do your
does your family and your friends react
in a great way when you
share things or do they come to you and
say like hey that's dope buddy like do
they say anything or
are they awkward yeah yeah yeah all of
my friends and my family have
um have have some of them have been like
hey i need to talk to you i'm like what
and they're like i've experimented too
and i've like
you know i've kind of experimented with
my sexuality or
or i've had some friends be like so how
sobriety i think i need it
um you know so it's all it's all awesome
it all comes out in a really really
positive way
on my side of the world you know with my
friends and my family and
um you know i think i don't know i think
it's just it's yeah it's cool to inspire
people to be more themselves and not
care you know not not have any shame
because that's something that i
instilled in myself early is i don't
know where it came from
but not to have any shame in in
being you you know so
i mean as long as you're a good person
and you all make mistakes and everything
but you know
yeah so i think it i think it helps it
helps a lot of my friends and my family
um just just just have no shame and not
really
just love yourself you know yeah
well other things that you put out
that's great is music
thank you awesome let's talk about this
single
uh past life it almost feels
autobiographical
it is yeah okay perfect how personal
is this song like what inspired it yeah
it's super personal so this whole ep
that i have coming out soon i started
working on it as i was getting sober
like the first song that i wrote for it
i wasn't sober yet
um and then i was really uh
you know needing to be sober and so
every single song
uh that i wrote for it basically is this
like story
of it was i just wrote what i knew and
at the time i was i was getting sober
and dealing with like oh wow this is
such a beautiful new
fresh light and way of being and now and
then you know i'm getting really
depressed and like i don't know what to
turn to
now now that i'm depressed and anxious i
just sit here with my
emotions and i have never done that
before so it's this up and down
rollercoaster ride of being sober why i
got sober
and how kind of difficult it is to be
sober and then also how beautiful it is
to be sober
so past life is kind of like uh
compiles all of those um experiences
into one song you know it's
past in a past life i was a low life
that's that's
me before i got sober and and you know
um i mean it's pretty much
self-explanatory right there and then
yeah uh the what the thing that that
really hits me the most for that song is
the bridge
um like the last verse that i do and it
just tells you
literally how i got in a way where i was
kind of an
uh an addict an alcoholic um
why it happened to me so it's like when
i was a kid i felt so alone
i had to escape so that i could feel
whole and like
when i was a kid i started acting at a
really young age and like i said earlier
i really felt disconnected from it one
because i grew up in a small town
and all of a sudden i had i had a job
where i was traveling the world and i
couldn't really relate to my friends and
some of them were picking on me a little
bit so
i felt that a place the only place i
felt safe
or home and then with acting i've always
i just don't i think there's a lot of
people who have a lot of different
agendas when they're actors and for me i
just wanted to love everybody and be
nice
and yeah you know and and you know
there's a lot of really really really
great actors out there who are also
really great people but when i was a kid
i for some reason mostly took to the
things that were negative about acting
and i just hated it so much
and i just wanted to separate myself and
not be viewed as an actor which is why i
got anxious when people recognize me
um because i didn't want to be
associated with that even at like 10
years old
i was like i don't want i feel this
feels icky yeah but i you know at the
same time i loved being creative and i
loved
i loved doing my job and uh
and it was also cool you know to see
myself i was proud of myself seeing
myself like on a big screen
i've never been one of those actors
that's like oh i can't watch myself i
love it i think it's
awesome i learned from it um i'm like
proud of myself i'm like that
it's like watching my family member or
something like do something really cool
um and then and then it goes uh
i had to escape so that i could feel
whole drift off to a place where no one
knew my name
a place i can get to by numbing the
taste and so that's you know it's very
like visual like uh i wanted to i wanted
to escape
and just so in order for me to feel
normal
i i turned to you know drugs
at a pretty young age um
because it made me feel like i i was
normal like i was a normal kid like i
wasn't uh you know so i started smoking
pot with my my
really good friends the best some of the
best friends i've ever had still to this
day
um and then you know we were the kids
that started experimenting
before other people other kids in our in
our school and so we were
we just were doing a lot of stupid [ __ ]
yeah i guess you can bleep that out
um i've been so good and cognizant i'm
not swearing
um uh so
yeah so i felt normal there and that's
what that line means i wanted to escape
where no one knew my name you know no
one knew the name that i've been
building for myself this like
this acting side of the world and my
reputation
by numbing the taste of taste for this
life
and something so great and 20 years
later i want to change so i put down the
poison and i put down the pain
it's heavy dude like it makes me kind of
well up every time i
i sing it or hear it um so yeah past
life is super personal for me and it is
very much an autobiographical
um and i'm super proud of it it's i'm
happy that i got to
like say all that stuff and what's so
cool about music
is that you get to be so creative and
poetic with how you say things
and that's one thing i've always loved
about songwriting
so uh yeah i love i love this song
so much and i'm really happy that it's
out
and it's my girlfriend's favorite song
and and when i first sent it to my
little brother it was his favorite song
and
yeah it's just uh it means a lot
it's really spiritual i don't know i put
a lot of
spirituality into that song without
really knowing it so whenever i hear it
i'm just like
whoa it takes me for like a ride
how are you going to perform this song
oh i can't wait
oh my god are you going to cry are you
going to be i might
there's there's in my in my previous
bands i've had songs where
like announcing it you know so my mother
passed away
about seven years ago now and i've i've
had uh
that's okay um i've had songs about her
and like as i'm like
it's usually the last song that we would
close with because it was our most
popular song and
there's a video of us playing our last
show in paris and
i'm like telling the audience like about
the song and i'm like
this one's for my mom it's called
whatever and i remember being in that
moment
and just like my voice was
shaking i was almost crying i was
holding it back but there's something
about
feeling those kinds of emotions when
you're performing that you can't like
mimic
it just happens like naturally and it is
it just it burns all it burns into your
memory forever
and it's really beautiful because
performing is so fun and punk rock and
sweaty
and you know you're getting really
connected with the kids but then
when that emotion comes out there's just
this juxtaposition of it being like
this real real real moment and that's
what i've always loved about music
especially the kind of music that i love
is punk rock pop punk it's like fun and
happy and goofy and like dancing and
crazy
but then also we sing about some really
intense topics
and so the juxtaposition of that just i
think goes really well with each other
yeah absolutely it was so great to talk
to you
what a meaningful conversation like yeah
that was really awesome
i had a great time thank you so much
you